mesdames et messieurs bonjour le procès
maurice papon l'audience d'hier fut en
tout point très particulière car on peut
dire que l'ancien ministre est
véritablement entré dans son procès j'ai
sauvé des juifs pendant l'occupation at
il affirmé
il s'est longuement exprimé sur sa
carrière l'ancien préfet de police de
paris a ainsi donné sa version sur la
répression policière contre la
manifestation du 17 octobre 61 en cours
de laquelle 200 algériens auraient été
tués emmanuel gagné joseph tual création
d'un carnet octobre 61 maurice papon
préfet de police de paris impose le
couvre-feu à la population algérienne
pour protester contre cette mesure
d'exception
le fln appelle à manifester le 17
octobre
trente mille algériens et leurs familles
se rassemblent à paris en face dix mille
hommes chargé de disperser la
manifestation interdite
la répression policière sera impitoyable
bilan officiel de morts et 64 blessés
pour le fln il y a plus de 200 tués hier
à l'audience
maurice papon a parlé d'une vingtaine de
victimes des dissidents qui aurait été
assassinée par des commandos du fln
c'est une contre vérité historique
flagrante faut aussi quand même tenir
compte de la parole des témoins et des
acteurs ce que maurice papon évidemment
oublier absolument de mentionner dans
ses interventions c'est à dire qu'il
espèce de négation du fait historique
sur le 17 octobre 61 avocats du fln
pendant la guerre d'algérie m oussedik
va plus loin
maurice papon en 61 ce serait une
répétition de l'histoire en lui un parti
une mission bien précise cacher le fln
dans la région parisienne et il a mis en
place des méthodes qu'il avait
certainement dû utiliser durant
l'occupation semer la terreur au sein de
l'immigration afin de lâcher pari de
l'organisation
que s'est il exactement passé le 17
octobre 1961
quelle est la responsabilité de maurice
papon dans la répression policière
pour répondre à ces questions il faudra
attendre 2021
à cette date les archives révéleront
peut-être lors douloureux et tragique
secret
à présent la situation